and division is a new research project
with the Intel Science and Technology
Center and embedded computing which is
located at Carnegie Mellon and the idea
is to transform the future of retail to
look both at the shoppers perspective
and to transform their viewpoint and
then to look at the retail operations
perspective and to transform their
viewpoint the idea for nd vision was
born out of me being a shopper I go to a
lot of stores and I find it very
difficult to find the items I want and
sometimes I leave the store if I can't
find the item I want and at the same
time you get to understand that a lot of
store staff don't quite know where all
the items are located either and you see
a crying need for there to be real-time
product information in everyone's sense
the store staffs hands as well as the
shopper sense and what we're really
trying to do is to build technologies
that put that kind of real-time
information into shoppers hands as well
as the store staff sense retail staff
face many challenges including those
traditionally felt by retail operations
inventory management customer service
staying on top of ahead of consumer
trends and of course watching that
bottom line additionally we find
ourselves facing the relatively new some
new challenges centered around mode the
potential mobile computing offered
through smartphones and tablets
consumers and store environments today
are educated have competitive
information at their fingertips with
very current technology they have
limited time and are bombarded with
information their service expectation
has never been higher so and division
consists of multiple different
technologies they're all embedded
technologies in the true spirit of us
being an embedded Center we have two
parts to this there's a digital sign
which has detailed 3d maps of the store
and then there's a robot that's
constructing these maps to go on the
digital sign right so let's look at each
of these at a time we have a robot that
goes through the store its navigating by
itself which means autonomously through
the store its scanning store shelves and
aisles and constructing a detailed 3d
map it's trying to find out where every
single product is down to the shelf and
the aisle and once it has all this
information it puts it together and
sends it to the store staff so that in
real time they can find out where
everything is if it sees a gap or a void
in a shelf it knows that there's
something wrong there it's trying to
figure out where things have been
misplaced
it's also trying to do counts of
different inventory inside the store and
send this all to the store staff so
that's the retail operations side now we
haven't forgotten the shopper either so
from the shopper side we have all this
real-time information that store staff
have but load it up for the shopper to
enjoy welcome to the CMU store Plano
gram and here you see that big digital
sign which is inside the store at the
moment this digital sign shows the 3d
real environment of the CMU store so
let's go inside here is a map and you
can jump to the different location I am
going in the right in the middle of the
store and we can see here though the
store from this particular point and we
can browse through that different items
as we can see that here I'm looking at
the CMU Stroh a CMU mug and it's price
and its features there is a discount
connected to that we develop a
smartphone app in that as you can see
that there is a shopping list of mine
six items are there in the shopping list
this is a CMU specific items and you can
see that all these three six items are
located in two different different
locations in the store and in the
particular location where I am currently
I can see that this number four item is
particularly located over there along
with the number four item we can see
that we can even look at the media
connected to that item and even we can
have a trailer of that particular DVD
and here this is a very famous lecture
from Randy pause I believe any vision
can make a real difference in retail the
potential labor savings associated with
robotically controlled inventory
management as well as the potential
impact it could have on the distribution
of accurate store specific planograms
are both exciting additionally it has
the ability to integrate some of the
benefits of a virtual shopping
experience into a brick-and-mortar store
such as improved navigation and fast
product location it has been exciting to
work on this project because Carnegie
Mellon University has an entrepreneurial
culture that's very research oriented
weather and division we're just getting
started we are very fortunate to have a
pilot partner with the Carnegie Mellon
store it's unheard of and unprecedented
for a research group to have access to a
production environment a production
store where not only can we explore the
challenges they face every day
but we can work with them side-by-side
to deploy pilot and study new retail
experiences we'll take this from the
small pilot that we have in the store to
larger pilots in more production
environments to researching even more
technologies that will affect retail in
the next 10 years to come